we just talked about senator camel
Harris so far she's gotten a free pass
from the press on her presidential run
they want her to be the next president
so they are overlooking her background
she is a former prosecutor as you know
but the press has let her rebrand as a
crusader for prison reform no one's
called her on it until last night
congressman Tulsi Gabbard of Hawaii
definitely called her on it watch this
there are too many examples to cite but
she put over 1,500 people in jail for
marijuana violations and then laughed
about it when she was asked if she ever
smoked marijuana from death row until
the courts forced her to do so she kept
people in prison beyond their sentences
to use them as cheap labor for the state
of California there is no excuse for
that and the people who suffered under
your reign as prosecutor oh you owe them
an apology was an electric moment it
might be why congresswoman Gabbard was
the most googled candidate since the
debate last night she joins us tonight
congressman thanks a lot for coming on
thanks so I haven't heard anybody say
wait you said why are you the first
person to say this look voters deserve
to know the truth you know the decision
that the American people have before
them is a critical one the decision that
Democrats have before them about who
their nominee should be is a very
important one they deserve to know the
truth about the candidates that are
before them and especially on this issue
of criminal justice reform that's
impacting so many people across this
country because it is so broken and and
it is an unjust criminal justice system
Senator Kamala Harris was in a position
to be able to make a difference in that
when she was serving as Attorney General
and as I pointed out last night she did
not fulfill that promise that she claims
to have which is to be a champion for
the people be a champion for the
oppressed in fact she did the exact
opposite she made decisions that ended
up hurting people that ended up hurting
minorities hurting poor people in the
state of California which is concerning
to me for someone who
to be the president United States and
and frankly who's claiming to be a
prosecutor president so I I think this
is a really interesting debate this this
topic deserves a real debate you have a
perspective she's got a perspective you
know let's hear them both she would not
engage with you and that's what I found
contemptible but also fascinating rather
than rebut what you said she dismissed
you in her spokesman later dismissed or
even more savagely as a Putin apologist
what do you make of that you know a
couple of things first of all what I was
sharing was not a matter of opinion
these are widely reported facts and
reports about her tenure as Attorney
General in California her career as a
prosecutor and we're not talking about
something that happened you know 30
years ago or 50 years ago this is these
are things that she did in her last job
just before she was elected as US
Senator and she should be held to
account for them she's claimed to be
very proud of this record so answer for
it the voters deserve to know but you're
right she refused to answer the question
she refused to engage on the debate
stage and the responses from her and her
campaign after the debate was basically
to lob cheap smears and basically say
that I'm a traitor or a foreign agent or
a Trojan horse or whatever it was and
trying to feed those talking points to
the media so you know this is concerning
on many levels about how a Senator
Harris would govern as president that if
there are those who are critics of her
or her record you know for me I'm I'm a
two-time veteran of Middle East
deployments I'm a soldier
currently still serving in the Army I'm
a sitting member of Congress and she's
smearing me in this way imagine what she
would do to anyone else you know as
president he's got so I think it's a
fair point
it's a fair point it's it's a it's the
it's the the first refuge of the
contemptible I think what did you think
of CNN's debate the way they they ran it
were you satisfied with it I think it
had a little more decorum than we saw in
the first debate but you know look I
wish there was a
a more fair and balanced approach in how
every candidate would have the right
amount of time to be able to address
these important issues that we face
there are many of them 60 seconds and 30
seconds there are short periods of time
to be able to dig into these issues so
this is where I'm looking forward to
being able to continue to build the
support for our campaign to make it to
the qualifications for the next debates
and in September in October yeah I mean
the one place you don't want to be in
Washington is outside the status quo as
you are that's when you start getting it
from from all sides obviously Tucker
this is this so you know a lot of the
conversation around this and the things
that we're talking about again really
come down to valuing this role this job
of president and that most
responsibility of commander-in-chief and
appreciating the freedoms that we hold
dear in this country you know if I have
the honor and privilege of serving as
president I can guarantee you that if
there are critics to my record or people
who disagree with my policies I'm not
going to to label them as foreign agents
or traitors having this vigorous debate
is a part of who we are as a country and
it's something that we've got to
appreciate and actually honor the voters
and the people of this country and
making sure that we're providing them
with the truth and the information that
they need to make the best decision
possible amen
Tulsi Gabbard thanks a lot for coming on
tonight thank you